Hey, I'm Jad Abumrad. I'm Robert Krulwich. This is radio lab, the podcast.
And we're going to St Louis. Yeah. Nice, nice and direct.
He likes that because cause he lived, he's mom lives there. But,
but you'll like that because you're about to meet something. Somebody unusual.
Unrelated to my mother. Thankfully this comes from our producer pap alters.
It's the story of a rescue. A double rescue. Really.
It's when we've been wanting to tell for a while. Pat Walters.
So a few months ago I went to St Louis because I'd heard this story about a guy
who had this pet that basically saved his life. Then the pet
is a bird. It's about this guy named Jim Eggers. Oh, you're recording.
And in 2005 Jim was living by himself in a little apartment in St Louis working
in a Halloween industry. It was the winter.
So Jim had just finished up his latest season at the local haunted house,
known the Halloween stuff for 19 years. What do you do?
Most of the time I've been in costumes and so forth, or wear masks, you know,
like jumping out from behind dark corners and scaring people.
I can scream and you know, go nuts.
Which is kind of a strange Gig for a guy like Jim because he has a really hot
temper. What's your, what's technically your diagnosis?
I have a bipolar disorder with psychotic tendencies and what that pretty much is
when I'm having a mood swing or whatnot,
I can become extremely dangerous and violent. While I was there,
he was totally calm, but Jim tells me that once he feels a mood swing,
he start coming on.
It feels like real strange and Tinguely might just be a few seconds before all
of a sudden, boom. Here you are. Like the incredible hulk. Yeah.
Have you ever, have you ever physically attacked?
Similar to hurt them? Yeah.
Jim's known around his neighborhood for just losing it from time to time.
He shouts at people in the street, punches, dents in people's cars.
One time he even poured hot coffee from a second story window onto his
neighbor's head. I go off on people and it's horrible.
And if you ask Jim, he'll tell you, this all goes back to when he was seven,
age of seven. I lost my kid brother in a Mississippi River.
I just saw him drown. And um, you saw, you saw him driving?
I witnessed him drowning. We wandered away from home.
We were not properly supervised by my parents. And uh,
I told my brother not to go over into the river because it was d he didn't
listen to me and then the current dragged him down.
I saw him Bob up and down three times.
And the third time he didn't come back up and I was pleading with God,
you know, crying, please bring him back. I'm going to be in trouble.
And when Jim's parents found out they blamed him, you know, it was my fault.
My brother drown. I should've been. Yeah,
I should've saved him. And in other times they told me that, you know,
they wish it was me that died instead of my brother. And then when he was 16,
Tim's mom threw me out of the house. She just said one day, get out Jim.
She said she didn't want me over there anymore. Get Out. After that,
Jim's life kind of spiraled out of control.
He ended up living on the streets for years and just getting angrier and angrier
at everyone around him.
And then in 2005 which you are part of the story begins.
Jim Did something that got him in very serious trouble.
Tell me about the archbishop situation. Okay.
As far as the art,
he'd been reading news reports about sexual abuse in the Catholic Church.
And for reasons that aren't entirely clear,
Jim had become convinced that the local Archbishop, Archbishop Raymond Burke,
was involved in covering the stuff up,
bailing out priests that have sexually assaulted children and so forth.
And one day he was watching the news and he saw Burke on there,
like on the 12 o'clock news, talking about something. I can't remember what.
And at that point I snapped and picked up a phone,
dialed the archdiocese. I asked him to connect me to his office,
which at like 80 hits they did. And when they did, I told them,
you know, I ought to come down and kill you. I said,
I may even do that Sunday, a couple of hours later,
Jim went out to run some errands and when I head out the door here were the
police
[inaudible]
Jim ended up getting sentenced to a year of probation,
just a few weeks into his probation.
Something happened that would basically set the story that we're telling about
Jim in motion like a year's probation does a typical Sunday morning and Jim's at
church and he runs into this couple of these people that owned variety bird shop
in valley park. The husband stopped me and said, well,
we know where you can get an African gray pair.
And they told me that she came with a cage. I say, why? Why,
why would they approach you? Well,
I was putting $100 aside every month to pay for a baby African gray parrot and
you have to understand that Jim has kind of an animal in that he's had dogs and
cats, Guinea pigs and stuff like that his whole life. Never a bird.
But when Jim read about these African gray parrots and became kind of obsessed
with getting one because I knew they were highly intelligent and they were a lot
of fun.
So when the birdshot people came up to Jim and said we can get you an African
gray parrot and she comes with the cage for $550 Tim thinks to himself that's
like half what I was going to pay. So he says, you know,
I'll go ahead and take it cause I was too good of a deal to pass up.
There was a catch though. The bird wasn't at the shop.
It was being sold by this local kid who's just trying to get rid of her.
I went over there and she looked absolutely horrible cause it does good.
Didn't take care of her.
She's about a foot tall. You want some peanut butter? She had a black beak.
Pretty yellow eyes too. Piercing yellow eyes. Right. Red Tail feathers.
But when Jim First Sar,
oh she didn't have any flight feathers in her left wing cause she'd torn all of
them out. Yeah. She was plucking her feathers,
which is this awful thing birds do when they get really stressed. And Hey,
I mean, she looked horrible. I almost want to say no after I saw her.
But he knew he couldn't just leave her there. So he paid the kid, took her home,
give her lots of loving and care. And within like three days,
she bowed her head. [inaudible]
that means she pretty much bonded with me.
[inaudible]
I would like the third week I owned her, I was in a,
another room on the telephone and he said, hey, jam.
Do you want a beer? And it's like, I don't drink beer.
She would say that to you. She asked me if I wanted a beer and then she'd ask,
uh, tell me, uh, uh, stuff like,
will you get me a beer? You know, made me choke on my coffee.
But a few weeks later, Sadie's started imitating gym. Yeah.
She'll impersonate a little chuckle that I do. It's like,
yeah,
it's even better than Elmo could laugh. It has.
Sadie spent more time with Jim. She learned to say words and phrases.
And then one day, uh, several weeks after I had her,
something kind of wonderful happened.
I came home and I was like in a really bad mood and I knew I had to do
something.
One of those moments when Jim could just feel he was about to lose control.
I was trying to talk myself into calming down. What would that,
what would that sound like? I was talking to myself and tell myself, calm down,
you'll be okay. Everything's fine, you know,
and you know it's not so bad. And then she started repeating that
same calm down, you'll be okay. Everything's fine. Exactly.
Just like Jim was saying, word for word. I was like, wow. And it's like,
and it gives me an ideal,
Jim started rewarding Sadie every time she said something that might help calm
him down. Like, you know, Oh, you'll be okay. Treat,
everything's fine is not as bad as you think. Treat shut up, treat.
I don't want to hear a treat. I love you jam and you'll make a kissing sound,
treat, treat. It just goes on and on and on.
So Jim went online and actually found this special kind of cage that you can
carry around on your back. Then I took her with me just everywhere.
Even got her registered as a service animal.
Kinda like a seeing eye dog mean everywhere. Where would you go with her?
I've taken her into churches.
I'm taking it or board the public buses. Take her to the gym.
Yes.
I've even taken her into like a couple of casinos through here and demonstrate.
He had a pretty good situation when Jim started feeling himself get mad,
he'd tell himself calm down. Sadie would repeat him.
But then one day a few years ago, he did something that went beyond mimicry.
Tim says he doesn't exactly remember the first time it happened.
I can't think of any thing right now cause I'm like blanking out.
But it probably went something like this.
Jim's just out in the neighborhood one day.
It's got Stadi in her little backpack cage and something happens that sets Jim
off. I don't know.
A car cuts him off at the crosswalk and immediately Jim starts getting that
tingly feeling. Yeah.
And then in the split second fraction of a moment before Jim starts to talk
himself down, like he does calm down. Jim Calm down. He hears calm down. Jim
[inaudible]
from Sadie. Exactly. She says at first. Yeah.
Wow. Like she,
she like she knew what was in his mind or inside him like before he even did
anything. Yeah. She know.
She, she can sense that. How do you suppose that was happening? I mean was she,
I don't know. I mean Jim thinks maybe she can like
feel a change in the way he's moving a, you know, my,
I have like body tremors when I'm starting to really get furious.
Maybe Sadie can pick up on those trimmers and Jim says this just kept happening.
She does it all the time and you know,
makes you stop to think if I would go off on a person or something like that,
you know, I wouldn't have any remorse or anything, but I mean,
just a little innocent animal.
It seemed to know him in this really intimate way.
[inaudible]
which kind of blew my mind. Yeah. But
Cindy didn't do it while I was there,
so I left him this tape recorder and asked him to try to get something like this
on tape just so I could prove it to people. Hello,
my name is James Eggers and I'm standing here with my parents, Sadie.
She's standing here right next to me on her little perch. See something.
You can say something to the c something to the microphone. Oh,
week or so later I got the tape back you have to say and said he was on there
saying all kinds of things like, hello. Hello.
She said her name. She said good girl.
Things that I could imagine Jim saying to her,
but did you ever get a sense from anything?
She said that there was a kind of weird intuitive exchange happening or
something? Not really, but I thought if it happens as often as Jim says,
it happens that someone in his neighborhood must've seen it. Yeah,
so I called this woman who runs a coffee shop around the from his house.
Ask her if she'd seen it. She hadn't. Oh.
Then I figured I could call the company that runs the buses and the trains that
Jim Rides every day thinking that maybe one of their drivers would have seen him
get upset about something and nothing.
And then I called Jim's best friend Larry and I figured if anyone has seen this,
it would be Larry because he's around them like all the time. He hadn't either.
Huh. So I called Jim to ask if I was like missing anybody. He didn't answer.
So I left a message, left another message. Then finally, hello.
Hi Jim. I got him on the phone. It's pat again.
Yeah, go ahead.
Um,
it seems like nobody else has ever seen her or heard her say those kinds of
things to you.
Well, she's definitely has said those, but I mean,
she's not gonna say the same thing day,
but he talks to me. Right.
But has anyone ever seen her talk you down from being mad?
No, because most of the time people aren't around me.
When I'm having a mood swing,
they started to wonder like,
is this the kind of thing a parent is even capable of?
So I decided to check. Hello. I call it the scientist. I'm Dr Irene Pepperberg,
adjunct associate professor at Brandeis University.
She's basically the world's expert on African gray parrots. So I asked her,
have you, have you ever heard of anything like this before? Not exactly,
but it doesn't surprise me. In fact,
Irene told me that something kind of similar. It happened to her once.
I mean there's this,
with this parrot named Alex that she worked with for like decades.
Irene told me that whenever Alex would get out of line preening and instead of
working or budding in with the others,
birds when he should be quiet so that we can train them. We'd say to him,
calm down, just calm down.
And one time I come storming into the laboratory cause I've just come from a
horrible faculty meeting when I was in Tucson.
And Alex takes one look at me and he says, calm down. Really?
Yeah. And I actually stormed off and I said something to the effect of,
don't you tell me to calm down?
And I went into my office and slammed the door and Irene says that a parrot like
Alex or Sadie probably doesn't know what calm down means or you'll be,
you'll be okay. Jim. She may not know what each of those little phrases mean,
but she knows that when she says calm down, Jim calms down.
So she has learned from association that that will bring her flock mate back to
normal, which is a big deal for parents.
Irene says because they're priced so they're constantly looking out for each
other, trying to keep from getting eaten. And it's eighties case,
she's in a flock of two with this point.
So if she wants to feel comfortable while preening or eating,
she needs to know that he's going to be watching out for her. Remember,
she doesn't have a big flock. She has him.
Wow. So in the end, what do you make of all this? Well,
I mean I can't prove that she does the things Jim says she does.
[inaudible]
but on the other hand, everyone I talked to you around,
Jim says that whatever is happening between them is keeping him from threatening
people on the street from punching, dents in people's cars.
It's just keeping him a better guy. Yeah.
So maybe it doesn't matter.
I don't care if anybody believes me or not. You know, it's not,
I'm not here to prove anything to anybody. That's not the point.
The point is, I know what she does and that is that.
No. Can you
see hello?
Number? [inaudible] no,
don't eat no eat. Gotcha, Gotcha, Gotcha,
Gotcha, Gotcha, Gotcha, Gotcha. No links.
Do Pat Walters
come on, fly home
and to [inaudible] good girl into gym. Yep.
See, who do you looking at? Huh? And to you for listening? I'm Jad. I'm Robert.
See you. He looks sleepy.
She's got her eyes focused on me and trying to figure out what you,
what you're doing with the my best. Yeah. And get you some coffee.